yeah welcome to this video playing
international master lights like who is
that from Germany Martine some Xander
yeah okay me some longtime Bundesliga
player first league in Germany so I'm
going for a philidor type of setup right
some 30 doll I played that for a while
ok yeah the various ways to play that
now with a 5 form you can also play but
be six but then it's got d5 hmm doesn't
play that ok sugar clip should be seven
even yeah problem ok probably wants to
go 92 to g3 this is in fact a good idea
ok I prepare a bishop f8 so that I have
g6 available don't want to see a knight
coming to a five this position is quite
similar to on 212 a ruler pairs b5
problem at some point I need to do that
I can play C form it's got c4 now after
which are not so sure what I would i
play now hmm I should have thought about
that a bit longer i am not saying I'm in
trouble but I don't I don't really want
to take here maybe I need to it takes
with the bishop that's a really really
ugly looking from me hmm take here maybe
it takes here then be fine it takes on
b5 not apply c5 which is at least
complicated and if he takes with a piece
I can consider to play C 5 + B form it
takes on b5 I go c 5 keeping the pawn
yeah maybe that's not too bad yeah the
question is now see 5 or not see if I'm
and before so probably not so bad I
wonder however about before about you
can take its hanging ok so let's go
ahead c5 after the Bishop Guth I can on
Toby form
at least my bishop on be stamina so
getting activated nicely here the pawn
on d6 some looks weak but it's still not
easy to want to win it ok I was I was
just thinking about me what the heck is
he is he calculating it must be
something out of the ordinary as it is
interesting moves its course hmm yeah
this can get ugly yeah if I take it
huh it looks very very risky to take
this
okay come on practical decision just
don't believe that don't want to take it
with one minute on the clock if he goes
tonight age six now I can take it take
d3 I hope this is working it's not maybe
he's got night h5 and my landlord may I
doesn't mm okay mm-hmm yeah this was
strong probably I mean if I can take it
then they're not but ok so quickly let's
get get this going quickly
93 if that is that what's necessary then
the sacrifice wasn't wasn't so great
maybe I could have actually taken and
take you for yeah yeah yeah I some
retreating
fig.6 is still weak
for maybe can can play the very
directive phone
I'm running directly into native 527
yeah okay so maybe it wasn't working but
it's looking dangerous you just wanted
to prepare for just not bad of course
still it feels like he could have maybe
called me sometime before yeah this is
not the best pretty sure about that
probably maybe still okay for white or
good for white but hard to believe that
this was the absolute best way to play
f5 through kiss 6 now don't want that
nightly for is the move I want to
prevent
oopsie 8
okay so check
hmm couldn't take it really
28 seconds mmm yep this is this is a
problem the position is still tricky for
me of course check time morning yeah now
the position is not not maybe maybe not
a choice good Bishop g6
okay yeah well I have no time check the
position really wasn't a problem anymore
not at all but 10 seconds check check
yeah no I'm not black is probably
winning but it doesn't really met him
check Jack forfeits on time yeah just
two seconds and I get to bond get both
bones um yeah I know I was probably
really outplayed here that didn't
understand one of night f5 another five
was probably winning at any point here I
really set up the pieces in a way that
it should be working f 1 95 95 wind step
so not too surprising it's just too much
on this position this is just bad and
here Knight f6 I don't think that that
black is Sam in huge trouble anymore can
go here you can take on the eighth egg
on f5 she didn't do just to treat it
yeah you have 20 seconds otherwise I
think it's not check not too much of a
problem Abhishek reform yeah now it's
equal but okay I don't have any time but
then the interesting question also is
could I have taken interestingly the
computer let's check it briefly computer
doesn't want to take
but down let's consider I was young lee
thinking about this and I asked myself
how to untangle and it wasn't clear to
me I cannot move this Bishop cannot miss
the night cannot move that night term if
I try to to play some some sector-22
minimizes activity like this he just has
a form it doesn't take it with the
bishop yeah the computer is already also
quite optimistic about what's what's
game iam yeah so my g5 was probably okay
at least practically um yeah instead of
before I could have taken here all night
you from ok I couldn't have taken I
didn't consider it at all but it wasn't
working so yeah and here I need to
improve somehow maybe not g4 or
something I have my problem is I have
too many pieces here if I tried a bit of
pieces it should be ok night energy
forum that's a good news and now I'm in
this in this passive yeah this is again
working of course check that black
explodes it did do that however yeah
still sell f4 not at five so probably
instead of this I need to play with like
this year but this idea so it probably
should take and then I'm not so so much
in danger of getting overrun here night
f5 coming all the time
there's also this move in the mix yeah
this is probably okay at least a
playable game for blood alright thanks
for watching